i have to tell you that a lot of people
are excited
because apparently there's a lot of
vaccines in the pipeline yep
and people think maybe maybe all of us
will get vaccinated in the next month or
so which is exciting yeah
but i think there's something we're
going to miss
i think that once audiences come back
and they're they're packed in here and
they're making all that noise
we might miss this quietness yeah
we might miss the fact that you and i
can just talk to each other
in this kind of environment without i
mean first of all
we lose i think eight minutes of show
when i come out up top and people are
just like oh my god
it's him you know ah you know what i
mean and they're like what's wrong with
them
like when they no they're not saying
that there's a lot of i thought you
meant something else
no no there's a lot of uh you know whoo
whoo whoo
you know and it's great very few humans
have ever known what it's like
uh to be um you know worshipped in that
way
yeah but my point is we lose a lot of
valuable showtime and then uh i talked
to you and you're like candy
and there's a lot of shrieking and
howling and people throwing
bras at you and panties and that's right
wanting me to put them on just
yes oh no i obviously need support yeah
yeah they
they want you to wear it yes they're
they're unmentionables
um and you do which again that's another
four minutes of you
taking off your clothes and putting on
yeah
yeah and that's again that's all fine
and good
but then there's a lot of woo woo
throughout the show and
this right here this is about as real as
it gets
yeah it's pretty much there's a couple
of people helping us out here but it's
pretty much an abandoned theater
this is all meat no filler yeah
you get this kind of energy
between the two of us right
be good when those audiences come back
don't you think it'll be nice it'll
frankly
you know yeah just uh
just to hear and feel something
something